well I think he's one of the big figures
of the 1980s of thatcherism really with
Mrs Thatcher herself Jeffrey Howe and
Michael hesseltine he was the brains if
you like who put in the economic
structure behind thatcherism his big
thing you know one of the most dramatic
moments till quasi quatteng's Kamikaze
budget was his budget where he
dramatically reduced the top rate of tax
uh to 40 percent and in the process and
this has become sort of part of Tory
myth ever since actually brought in more
money from taxpayers than the higher
rate which has been as high as 80
percent at one stage so that was a
dramatic move he liked to say that every
budget he removed the tax from the
statute book and he then went on really
to build thatcherism with the big bang
in the city freeing up Banks and
investment organizations encouraging
privatization so he was a big architect
of that altruism although ironically he
was probably also the figure who rung
the bell for the end of thatcherism when
he resigned in 1989 because Mrs Thatcher
was no longer taking advice from her
ministers but had her own advisors
around Walters and a year later she was
gone but he was a mischievous character
as well I was going to ask you tell me
about him personally I mean we know he
had two famous kids yeah well he had a
number of famous children of course
Nigella Lawson uh the cook and also
Dominic Lawson who edited The Spectator
in the Sunday Telegraph now writes for
the Sunday Times uh in all I think he
had six kids one of them Thomasina died
young of cancer and he was of course we
got used to it now kids in Downing
Street but when he was a number 11
Downing Street with his second wife
Therese he had two young kids one of
whom is now a school had mastered but
that was back then so
um massive weight loss yeah he also had
a diet book
um he lost a lot of weight when he left
office his two books actually his Dart
book was a bestseller but so strangely
enough were his Downing Street Memoirs
inside number 11 which are a kind of
primer for anyone interested in the
business of how government works and
have been very popular ever since but
you know he was a mischievous character
because having fallen out with Mrs
Thatcher because he was a pro-european
in his retirement he then became
probably the most respectable voice for
brexit uh making the economic case for
that he also took on the idea of climate
change not because he disagreed with
climate change but because he thought
that the economic cost of dealing with
it was not worth it uh that was his big
argument there but I mean last time I
saw him a few years ago
um I couldn't believe it he was wearing
a a stage coach cloak you know those
things layers and layers and layers and
I said to him you know it's very
impressive cloak and he said yeah I've
always wanted one of these and I went
around to all the London tailors to try
and find uh one who would make one for
me none of them would so in the end he'd
gone to a Hollywood Costume
[Music]
to have this uh this great cake amazing
did he make much impression in the House
of Lords
he more I think not within the House of
Lords more as a commentator on economic
Affairs he worked for a branch of
Barclays after he left office and and um
uh his influence I think was felt
internationally in a sense the House of
Lords itself was probably a bit too a
small arena for him but he was an
interesting guy because he had this sort
of reputation all along as being a great
Economist and he was intimidatingly
intelligent but I remember saying to him
interviewing here it's in the studio and
saying well you're an economist he said
no I'm not an economist I'm a journalist
which is very interesting yeah
um although he was sacked by The
Spectator wasn't he well he's editor of
The Spectator and then there was a
because of their reaction to the Vietnam
War yeah he opposed the Vietnam War and
there was a controversy although his son
went on uh in his footsteps to be editor
of it and he and um he you know he re he
was I mean we know as Chancellor as a
slightly kind of Rotan roly-poly figure
but in his youth in his 20s he was a
very
um the Old Guard are all leaving us at
him one by one yeah I mean well um we've
got a Hessel times celebrating his 90th
birthday Nigel Lawson was 91 when he
died Jeffrey Howe of course died some
time ago I think you know what's
interesting is probably today more
people have heard of Nigella Lawson than
have heard of Nigel Wilson although we
should say we're getting old Adam yeah
Nigel always insisted that it wasn't
vanity calling his daughter Nigella he
insisted he was naming her after the
rather beautiful flower loving the Mist
not after himself